Watch the official first trailer for Venom
Let there be Carnage at the 55th super bowl's
halftime show on the 7th of february on
cbs only in theaters this june rated r
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new venom 2 teaser trailer video this leaked
online recently and is claiming a bunch of
things one that sony is planning on actually
releasing a movie this year because they just
delayed the morbius movie but also that venom 2
is supposed to be rated r so i'll talk about that
but also kevin feige was talking about spider-man
3 and spider-verse stuff recently in the way
they're connecting venom and all these other
different movies so there is a lot of really
cool stuff happening in the background despite
the fact that 2020 was such a crap year 2021 will
hopefully be much better there's also a lot of
spider-man 3 stuff that's going to be happening
really soon too that i'll be doing videos for
so be sure to subscribe to get all those videos
if you're brand new to my channel but not to be
forgotten the super bowl still an actual thing
hoping for some big super bowl trailers i know
everyone's wondering where the spider-man 3
trailer is because it was around this time a
couple years ago in 2019 that they released the
first spider-man far from home trailer so we're
due for some new footage sony also just announced
that they delayed the morbius movie to october
originally it was supposed to come out in march
and sort of begin this big spider-verse crossover
that they're weaving through all these different
sony venom movies and the mcu spider-man movies
so as far as we know good news right now is that
venom 2 still currently coming out in june and
at least for right now it seems like that data is
safe but just don't hold your breath on anything
depending on how worried sony is about making
money this year they might push venom to a pg-13
rating and they might delay it a little bit and
just delay any potential super bowl trailer they
release so hopefully everything will work out
in the next month or so we'll actually see some
footage for some actual movies that we can buy
tickets for later this year but a lot of you were
also asking about what this cryptic tom holland
twitter post is all about he just posted this date
and everyone's wondering what it's for the date is
for thursday and i know everybody wants him to be
leaking the spider-man 3 trailer because that's a
very tom holland spoiler bros thing for him to do
so what makes a joker like you want
to join the united states army for
this guy had a face like death and every
other word out of his mouth was joker
but what he's actually teasing though is the other
movie that he made with the russo brothers called
cherry that's the trailer that they're releasing
on thursday i might do a video for it if it feels
like a slow day and there's no other big
spider-man news going on robert downey jr
was hyping it up with the russos and tom hall the
other day so if you're wondering why robert downey
jr is doing all these videos with tom hall in the
past couple of days in the russos it's not for a
marvel movie it's just for a separate movie that
robert downey jr is helping them promote in legit
spider-man 3 spider-verse news kevin feige just
did a big round of interviews for the Wandavision
series which is dropping episodes this friday
of course i'll be doing videos for that stuff
the director of wandavision also said that he
was working with the director of spider-man 3
john watts to help explain the flow of all the
multiverse stuff that's happening so apparently
in addition to setting up mcu x-men as well as
doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness Wandavision
also helps set up spider-man 3 but that doesn't
mean that spider-man is going to cameo during
Wandavision or anything like that but it does
make you a little more excited about the series
knowing that it's going to be connected to
spider-man 3 and also lets you know that they
are actually doing some legit spider-verse stuff
during that the way that kevin feige spoke about
spider-man 3 in all of his interviews though he
said that some of the rumors that people have been
posting about all the spider-verse stuff tobey
maguire andrew garfield some of that's true
some of it is not true that's just his way
of covering his bases but also confirming yes
we're definitely doing some spider-verse stuff
during that that also gets into the venom 2
venom spider-man crossover that's happening
later on because we have the tobey maguire
spider-man suit that shows up in the morbius
trailer and the fact that spider-man 3 and
doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness are big
crossover movies doctor strange major character
in spider-man 3 sort of like a big avengers
crossover spider-man also probably going to
have a cameo and crossover in doctor strange too
spider-man 3 comes out right before doctor strange
too so that's why i say those movies are probably
more connected than people think that they are
so no surprise that the multiverse would play
a role in how the story of spider-man 3 plays
out if they're saying even Wandavision is
helping set up spider-man 3 the whole big
thing with Wandavision is it just sort of sets
off their big marvel phase four multiverse plot
but that also provides them with an opportunity to
explain future venom spiderman crossover and how
that plays out just laying the ground work for
all that to make sense because it allows kevin
feige to avoid having to deal with a ton of venom
explainers and larger sony verse stuff inside the
mcu if he doesn't want to right now though the big
live-action spider-verse crossovers that we know
about in spider-man 3 venom 2 and the morbius
movie are starting in the morbius movie because
at least originally that movie was supposed to
come first in all these big spider-man crossovers
we were supposed to see the big spider-man easter
eggs like toby maguire spider-man suit on the wall
here with the words killer on it because he's
been framed also sort of meta referencing what
was happening with tom holland's character at the
end of spider-man far from home being framed for
mysterio's death but at the same time letting us
know that the sony venomverse movies are connected
to the spider-man movies just backed up by the
fact that also in the movie michael keaton's
vulture character shows up in the same white
prison jumpsuit that he was last seen wearing in
the spider-man homecoming post-credits scene with
the scorpion and apparently during that scene when
he's talking to morbius it's only supposed to be
a cameo seem pretty minor but he's just supposed
to be there purely for the purpose of setting up
the new version of the sinister six team that's
going to overlap between the sony venom movies
and the mcu spider-man movies in the future
then the venom 2 movie was supposed to come after
that and even though the plot is mostly a light
adaptation of the carnage origin story that's why
they're calling it let there be carnage instead
of maximum carnage because that is a much cooler
title why wouldn't you call it maximum carnage
mostly because they're saving that story for
a later sequel in an escalation of the carnage
story but during venom 2 in addition to doing
full-blown carnage there was also talk of an
actual tom hall in spider-man cameo scene like
legit spider-man showing up nobody knew where
it was supposed to happen or what it was going
to look like so everyone just kind of assumed
it would be a post-credit scene stinger to set
up spider-man venom crossover in a later movie
then before we learned about all the tobey maguire
andrew garfield spider-man 3 spider-verse stuff it
was assumed that at least one of the spider-man
3 post-credit scenes would be teasing venom
crossover so there was always going to be some
level of spider bursts that they had to invoke
with all these big crossovers it's just that now
with all the new spider-man 3 news and all these
rumored castings they're rolling spider-verse
way harder than i think that anybody expected
like they definitely don't need to roll this
hard it was already going to be a huge movie
mostly because there's still that whole plot
with spider-man being doxed by mysterio having
to clear his name and they're already busy
setting up spider-man vs the sinister six
in the mcu so everyone just got a little worried
last year when we suddenly heard about a billion
other characters announced and rumored in the
movie like doctor octopus that's amazing wait
electro 2 what the what what kind of movie is this
i hope that tom holland's character gets a cameo
but remember kevin feige said that some of the
rumors are not true which i think means that just
all the other spider-verse stuff is mostly
just really small and short cameos like
most of them are only a couple minutes at best and
most of the movie is still tom hall and spider-man
clearing his name in an escalation of the mcu
sinister six related stuff for those of you that
are still getting really hyped up about venom
too though just to talk more about that movie
the whole thing with their story because they've
changed so much about the carnage and the venom
origin stories already inside that first venom
movie that was all before they had solid plans
for big tom hall and spider-man crossover so
even though venom 2 isn't going to completely
retcon the story of the first venom movie they are
going to sort of re-tune things just a little bit
creatively to make it more of a legit horror
film and sort of provide the opportunity for
spider-man to exist in this universe that's
why he doesn't have the spider-man symbol on
his chest yet is because they're saving that for
the big spider-man crossover so that after they
team up then the venom symbiote replicates the
spider-man symbol but based on some of the set
footage that we saw last year of them filming
at a church it does seem like they're trying to
at least include aspects of the original venom
origin story that we saw play out during the
tobey maguire spider-man 3 movie i'm just waiting
for like a funny twitter post or something from
topher grace where he jokes about waiting for
the call to come back as his version of venom
the big rumor right now though is that sony is
just waiting for tobey maguire to finish signing
his contract before they actually start promoting
all this big spiderburst stuff they're going to be
filming spiderman 3 outdoors really soon as well
so hopefully we'll actually see some more footage
from the set so whatever winds up happening of
course i'll do videos for it but leave all your
requests and your big questions about it in the
comments below my full Wandavision episode 1 and
episode 2 video is going to post friday make sure
you have alerts turned on so you don't miss those
my videos for that will post just like i did for
the mandalorian season 2 episodes every friday
there'll be a bunch more marvel trailers for
all the marvel phase 4 stuff coming in the next
couple of weeks too as well while Wandavision
is happening they'll use that to promote all
the other stuff they're releasing later this year
while you wait for everything click here for that
brand new Wandavision episode 1 scene and click
here for that brand new thor 4 kevin feige teaser
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next video!